so last week we had a preview of this
axios interview
between donald trump and jonathan swann
which aired
last night i've reviewed the full
interview
and this is truly the stuff of legends i
actually
my vocabulary was not uh
powerful enough to accurately describe
the contents of this interview so i had
to spend a bunch of time today
reading jack london in order to expand
my vocabulary to be better prepared to
describe what it is that we are about to
see
that's a joke by the way this may
actually be
the most damaging interview to donald
trump
that i have ever seen if you thought the
chris wallace interview two weeks and
two days ago on fox news sunday was bad
and it was this is arguably even worse
and what's
particularly spectacular about this
interview
is that jonathan swann calls out and
confronts donald trump on all those
things i've been saying during the last
five months of coronavirus
somebody has to call him out somebody
has to confront him well jonathan swann
did it
when trump lied about we have the lowest
death rate
jonathan swann checked receipts and had
trump pulling out papers that trump
didn't even understand
when trump uses his bogus talking points
or phrases like
people are saying jonathan swann says
who is saying tell me exactly who is
saying
and trump is never actually able to say
referring to vague books or whatever
let which trump doesn't read let's look
at some of this and we'll talk through
it here's a series of hilarious fact
checks and weird claims from trump
during
the vote by mail portion of the
interview and trump tries to claim that
absentee and mail-in are two different
things in this election
swan says it's the same thing trump says
vote by mail is new
swann says it's been around since the
civil war this is really really great
stuff
we have a new phenomena it's called in
it's called mail in voting
where you send where a governor it's
been used as a civil war
in terms of the kind of the kind of
millions and millions
of ballots they've never it'll be it'll
be bigger this year because of the
pandemic bigger
not bigger massively bigger yeah so
they're going to send
tens of millions of ballots to
california all over the place who who's
going to get them
i have a friend who lives in westchester
county i send applications
with universal mail-in voting absentee
voting is okay if you have to apply you
have to go through a process you have to
apply for failure
look okay okay let's do concrete let's
do that they're sending out
applications governors millions of
ballots
no they're not there's applications
there's
no way you can go through a mail-in vote
without massive cheating i honestly
don't understand
this topic with wikileaks the republican
party has an extremely well-funded vote
by mail program
your campaign puts out emails telling
people to vote by
correct your daughter-in-law lara trump
she did robocalls in california saying
it's safe and secure mainland voting
let me tell you the republicans we have
no choice that was an all-mailing race
let me tell you we went through world
war ii
you went to the polls you've had my
involved insistence because of the china
virus
was supposed to stay home send millions
of ballots all over the country
millions and millions you know you could
have a case
where this election won't be decided on
the evening of november third absolutely
this election could be decided two
months later maybe two months but what's
wrong with the proper mailing
decided many months later i have to use
the phrase
it's a verbal inkblot test it's just
throwing stuff
all over the place trump is frequently
using this thing
we might not know the results on
election night okay
i mean shouldn't we prioritize accuracy
over speed like why would it be so bad
if we didn't know the results
on election night is it that trump won't
be able to sleep for five days
not knowing that it's conceivable that
he may not
knowing that he may have lost the
election now then a ton of the interview
was about coronavirus and this is a
portion that we're going to want to look
at very closely donald trump start
making incorrect
starts making incorrect claims about
deaths
in the united states and actually pulls
out paper
so let's step through it one piece at a
time because this is really historically
embarrassing stuff now if you're
watching and not just listening
you're going to notice that as donald
trump is looking at various charts and
graphs that he pulls out
he seems to even struggle what it is
that he's looking at and ends up handing
stuff to jonathan swan take a look at
this
look at some of these charts i'd love to
we're going to look
let's look and if you look at death yeah
start to go up again well right here
the united states is lowest in
numerous categories uh we're lower than
the world lower the lower than europe
in what in what so this is already
amazing donald trump says
we are lower than the world and jonathan
swann is visibly confused and says what
what does that even mean we're lower
than the world in what
and so then trump starts handing papers
to jonathan swann
and things start to escalate very
quickly take a look
right here here's case death
oh you're doing death as a proportion of
cases i'm talking about death as a
proportion
of population that's where the u.s is
really bad well
much worse than south korea germany et
cetera you can't you can't do that you
have to
have to go by you have to go by
where look here is the united states you
have to go by the cases the cases why
not as a proportional population
what it says is when you have somebody
that has
where there's a case oh okay the people
that live from those cases
this is brilliant i mean this this is
just this is exactly the confrontation
that donald trump has needed all along
trump continues to insist that
the reason our numbers are skewed are
the number of tests that we do
and he keeps talking about our death
rate relative to the testing rate
i've talked about this before the case
fatality rate is a rate of deaths
relative to tests and trump continues to
insist
that testing skews numbers which is what
he says is actually the problem
and swann points out you know deaths per
population
not deaths per test is really what
matters
and trump is just barely able to even
keep up cognitively
it's surely a relevant statistic to say
if the u.s
has x population and x percentage of
death of that population no versus south
africa
by the cases we'll look at south korea
for example 51 million population
300 deaths it's like it's crazy
that i do you think they're faking their
statistics south korea
and advanced countries have a very good
relationship with the country
but you don't know that now that's a
really important moment
this is sort of a white flag moment for
trump
when you can't argue the facts anymore
when you've been
beaten on the facts and your arguments
if you can even call them that
fall apart you call into question
whether we can believe anything whether
we can know anything like this is a
complete white flag because
it stops the conversation it's actually
a really common crutch it's a basic
epistemological question that in a sense
we can always ask right you can always
turn to
how do we know anything how can we
uh what what really is true can we know
anything but
this is a crutch that stops the
conversation because it's like well then
anything you're saying is also subject
to that same question
it is a white flag when it is an
interview about facts
at any point you want you can always say
how do we know any fact is true
okay but that's not really where you go
if the facts are on your side and if
you're able to coherently put together
an
argument and trump then goes back to
holding up pieces of paper
that even he doesn't understand and just
continues handing them to the
interviewer
and they have spikes look here germany
low 9 000.
here's one right here united states you
take the number of cases okay look
we're last meaning we're first lost i
don't know what we're facing
as a whole again it's cases okay um and
we have cases
i mean these are majestic thousand
americans i understand
i understand on cases it's different no
but you're not reporting it correctly
jonathan
i think i am but if you take a look at
this other chart
look this is our testing i believe this
is the testing yeah
yeah we do more tests now wait a minute
well don't we get credit for that
and because we do more tests we have
more cases in other words we test more
we have
now take a look the top one that's a
good thing not a bad thing
at the top jonathan if if if hospital
rates were going down and deaths were
going down i'd say terrific you deserve
to be praised for testing but they're
all going in are they very
possibly sixty thousand americans are in
hospital you watch thousands
read the papers they usually talk about
new cases new cases new cases
i'm talking about death will you look
it's good enough death is way down from
where it was
it's a thousand a day it was two that
half thousand it went down to 500 now
it's going up again
the scariest part about this is that
under the most basic questioning like
these are simple pushbacks from jonathan
swan these aren't gotchas
this is what trump should have been
confronted with all along
he immediately becomes incoherent he has
to fall back on repeating things that
don't make sense
and you really get the sense that trump
doesn't understand what's going on
yes he also doesn't care but it's not
just that he doesn't care
he also doesn't get it he can't parse
the data he can't understand the facts
and here trump is confronted about his
constant refrain
that coronavirus is quote under control
when it's very clearly
completely out of control and take a
look at donald trump's response
they listen to every word you say they
hang on everybody they don't listen to
me or the media or fouchy they think
we're fake news
they want to get their advice from you
and so when they hear you say
everything's under control don't worry
about wearing masks
i mean these are people many of them are
older people more serious of control
yeah under the it's giving them a false
security i think it's under control i'll
tell you what how
a thousand americans are dying a day
they are dying that's true
and you ha it is what it is but that
doesn't mean we aren't doing everything
we can
it's under control that's really bad
right i mean
a thousand deaths a day this interview
was recorded a week ago we've had a
couple 14
1500 death days since and trump says
well it is what it is but it's under
control
either donald trump doesn't understand
language
or he will not concede ever
that this may not be under control but
trump just repeats it's under control
the deaths they are what they are but
it's under control it's like language
has no meaning anymore
and then they get back into testing and
cases take a look at that
i mean i've heard you say this big
countries don't test like we do
so they don't showcase it just a couple
of points on that i wasn't going to
continue on the testing but
you said it so we're testing so much
because it's spread so far in america
we're testing
so much because we had the ability to
test okay because we came up with
south korea jonathan we weren't even we
didn't even have a test when i took over
we didn't even have a test
now in all fairness why would you have a
test no test didn't exist
how would you ever talk okay there was
no test for this no
we didn't have a test because there was
no testosterone
in a very short order we got one test we
got another test it was broken
many of those tests are now obsolete
because we've you know it's called
science and
all of a sudden something's better so
jonathan swann here
doing a good job of calling out the
talking point that trump keeps using
that before trump was in office there
was no test for coronavirus yeah that's
right it's
a novel virus it's called uh covet 19
because of the year 2019 and
sometimes it seems trump is trying to
use this phrase we had no test when i
took over
to place blame on obama which is really
crazy
but sometimes what trump tries to use
that talking point for
is to say that the u.s was in a uniquely
difficult position relative to other
countries listen
we didn't have a test when i became
president but that was the case for
every country
in other words it was not just the u.s
that was facing a novel coronavirus with
no test
no other country had a test for it
because it was a novel coronavirus
nobody had a test and yet other
countries were able to get the virus
under control
let's keep going in this part of the
interview but because we tested
so many people 55 60 million people very
soon
we get cases you test some kid has even
just a little runny nose it's a case
and then you report many cases so we
look like we have more cases than
massive countries like china which by
the way doesn't report as you know
i i don't put any stock in china's point
is the point is
because we are so much better at testing
than any other country in the world
we show more cases now as you probably
know by now if you've been watching my
show
this is not true in terms of per capita
testing the united states has now crept
up to 18th in the world but the
important thing to understand
as jonathan swann attempted to point out
earlier is that
at this point a lot of countries don't
need to test
so now arguing we are doing the most
testing
even if true which it's not is no longer
equally relevant because the game is to
develop a testing program
early there are many countries now that
the us
is passing in tests per capita over time
because those countries don't have sim
people with symptoms they don't have
people to test because they have so few
cases early on remember when we were
50th 55th in testing per capita
that was the time to be testing to to
suppress the spread of the virus
many countries have done that so at this
point even bragging
about our testing per capita rate
becomes less relevant because
even though it's still only 18th in the
world a lot of the countries we've
passed since the countries
that are 25th 30th 40th in testing per
capita
they don't have anybody to test anymore
because they have so few cases it's
all just basic critical thinking and
stats stuff from high school
that trump doesn't get now at one point
donald trump was asked
about the recent passing of congressman
john lewis a civil rights hero
who trump barely acknowledged previously
and check out what donald trump says
immediately making it all about him
john lewis is lying in state in the us
capital how do you think history will
remember john lewis i don't know
i really don't know uh i don't know i
don't know john
lewis he chose not to come to my uh
inauguration he chose i don't
i never met john lewis actually i don't
believe do you find him impressive
uh i can't say one way the other i find
a lot of people impressive i find many
people not impressive but
no but i didn't find his story he didn't
come to my inauguration
he didn't come to my state of the union
speeches and that's okay that's his
right
and again nobody has done more right
more americans than i have i understand
he should have come but i think he made
a big mistake but
taking your relationship with him out of
it do you find his story impressive what
he's done
for this country he was a person that
devoted a lot of energy and a lot of
heart
to civil rights but there were many
others also
i don't know him he didn't come to my
inauguration he says twice
uh and i am the savior of black people
is what donald trump manages to turn
that into
trump cannot comment on anything outside
of his own relationship to the person or
the event or the material in question
and trump doesn't all lives matter here
this is equivalent to all lives matter
trump is asked about john lewis's
contributions to civil rights
and trump says lots of people
contributed to civil rights
that is again like well we're we're
talking here about
the victims of the boston marathon well
but people also died
in 9 11.
black lives matter well all lives matter
okay yeah but we're talking about black
lives right now
what about john lewis who just passed
away's contributions to civil rights
many people worked on civil rights
sick really really sick and then here's
our sort of uh dessert our denim on
trump once again wishing well to a
serial accused
child sex trafficker ji len maxwell
nice way to cap off the interview go all
over the country mr president the other
day a reporter asked you about galaine
maxwell
you said quote i just wish her well
frankly i've met her numerous times over
the years especially since i lived in
palm beach
but i wish her well whatever it is mr
president maxwell
has been arrested on allegations of
child sex trafficking
why would you wish such a person don't
know that but i do know that she has
she's been arrested for that her
friend or boyfriend epstein was either
killed or committed suicide in jail
she's now in jail yeah i wish you well
i'd wish you well i'd wish a lot of
people well
good luck let them prove somebody was
guilty i mean you do you know this
oh so you're saying you hope she doesn't
die in jail is that what you mean by
wish her well
her boyfriend died in jail and people
are still trying to figure out
how did it happen was it suicide was he
killed
and i do wish her well i'm not looking
for anything bad for her i'm not looking
bad for
anybody and they took that and i mean
she's a child sexually allegedly
big deal but all it is is her boyfriend
died he died in jail was he killed was
it suicide
i do i wish her well famous last words
maybe from donald trump i have never
seen anything like this
i thought 16 days ago that the fox news
chris wallace interview
was rock bottom as far as interviews are
concerned
no this is far far worse let me know
your thoughts i'm on
twitter at dpakman and remember that you
can get the daily audio
podcast excuse me the daily audio
podcast of the show
every single day right around 3 p.m
eastern time on whatever is your
favorite podcasting app
spotify google play pandora
iheartradio itunes whichever you prefer
get the daily audio podcast we'll take a
quick break
and be right back the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
welcome back to the program today's new
members of the day are
keith trussell not russell trussell
keith
trussell and jose martinez
thanks to both of you for your support
and also a big thank you
to charles babb who is today's longtime
sustaining member of the day
charles has been a member just shy of
five years you can grab a membership
at joinpackman.com the united states
postal service
is now thinking about closing post
offices
around the country ahead of a
presidential election in which we are
anticipating more people than ever will
vote by mail
because of this thing called the global
coronavirus pandemic
which has been acutely mishandled by
donald trump now we're going to be
talking today about a lot of angles on
vote by mail
including how to vote by mail but this
is
i think where it makes sense to start we
knew when it looked like vote by mail
was going to be a big deal this november
that the post office was going to be a
target and part of the reason why is
republicans love going after the post
office
even when there's not a pandemic and
when people are not particularly
planning to vote by mail trump loves
talking about
how the post office is inefficient
republicans love talking about
privatization ups
fedex they're better than the post
office the post office
is kind of a perfect target for people
like donald trump and many republicans
because you can talk about privatizing
while shrinking government while
attacking government inefficiency and
saying stuff like if the post
office can't even get it right how could
we possibly have the government handle
health care that's
often the way they like to talk about it
and then while we were already
suspicious about trump's plans for the
post office
trump goes and appoints a huge donor
from his campaign a donor to his
campaign rather louis de joy
as postmaster general who immediately
starts talking about
reevaluating the post office talking
about a fresh
look at the post office limiting
overtime hours for postal workers
and then we get a clearer picture of
what the plan is
we've now heard from democratic senator
joe manchin of west virginia
that he has been receiving letters that
there are plans
for closures of post offices in the
state
of west virginia which may just be the
very beginning of this strategy
when manchin sent a letter to trump's
new postmaster general to essentially
say
what on earth is going on here he got
some vague response
similar to what we we already talked
about you know we need to take a fresh
look at how the post office should be
run
now i actually found a document from the
congressional research service called
common questions about post office
closures
and it explains how and under what
circumstances post office branches can
be closed
and when you look at this document on
page nine it says
what is that process and uh
the the federal law around closing post
offices
includes that there must be adequate
notice of the intention to close or
consolidate branches
at least 60 days prior to the proposed
date of the closure
and if a decision is made to close a
post office everybody served by that
post office must be notified
and the post office has to wait at least
60 more days before proceeding with the
closure
anybody who is served by a post office
that may be closing
has the right to appeal the closure
and there will be up to 120 days to
consider the appeal
so if you just look at the calendar it's
already too late to close post offices
before the election
by the normal process how can you get
around this
i'm guessing you you understand the way
this is going to go
emergencies there is something called an
emergency suspension process
but the situations where you can use
such a process to close a post office
branch
is very very limited these are limited
situations for example
if the post office is in a building that
you rent from
you know a landlord a private landlord
and the landlord
closes the building as an example you
would be able to close the post office
the post office would have no choice in
that case but to close
sooner than the normal timeline but
right now we certainly don't meet that
standard and
if kids are going back to school you
can't really argue that it's safe for
kids to be in school but post offices
have to close
so here's the plan that they're cooking
up cut over time
if carriers can't finish their daily
deliveries without taking overtime
they have to bring the undelivered mail
back to the post office the next day
they've got to take out the new mail
plus the leftover stuff from day one
can't finish it by 5 pm
bring it all back to the post office day
3 you now have to deliver that day's
mail
plus the leftovers from day one and the
leftovers from day two i think you
understand that's part of the plan
and meanwhile look at whether
they might be able to shut down some
branches as donald trump continues to
publicly assail
the ability of the post office to
deliver
absentee ballots now that's the plan it
doesn't match up with reality
and the postal service has actually uh
said not trump's postmaster but
others in the postal service have said
we have that we've got this we can
handle
the the ballots that's really not a big
deal for us donald trump however
is going to continue casting doubt about
that and that's what we're going to talk
about next
donald trump lied for five
uninterrupted minutes during yesterday's
coronavirus press briefing
about vote by mail the question came
from right wing propaganda network
oan the way that the oan questions
typically work is that oan will set up
some
completely uh distorted softball
question for donald trump or his press
secretary kaylee mckenna
sometimes the question itself is so
disjointed that you can actually
see confusion on the face of the oan
reporter asking the question
like under sometimes the reporter
doesn't understand the question
they seem confused by their own question
and it's just basically like a carte
blanche for donald trump or kaylee
mckenney
to start ranting and raving about
whatever is on their agenda this time
the question was about
vote by mail and whether trump would do
anything
at the federal level to stop vote by
mail and donald trump
five minutes going going going lying
lying
lying let's uh jump right into it oem
thank you mr president in uh in our
nation's 243 year history there has
never been
a stronger push for mailing ballots to
determine a national election
are you considering at any point issuing
an executive order
addressing mail-in ballots and why do
you think some people are pushing it so
hard
well there's never been a push like this
for mail-in ballots and if you look at
the
new york congressional race which is a
disaster
carolyn it's been a total disaster they
have
they're six weeks into it now they have
no clue what's going on
and i mean i think i can say right here
and now i think you have to rerun that
race because it's a mess nobody knows
what's happening
with the ballots and the lost ballots
and the fraudulent ballots i guess
uh i think you probably have to take the
carolyn maloney race and run it over
again how can you do this and this is a
small race
with literally thousands of people small
thousands
and it's all messed up you look at
paterson new jersey it's all messed up
almost every one of these and these are
small easy to control
they should be able to do this easy now
you're talking about like
nevada where last two nights ago they
they went out and in the darkness of
night without
people without having any meetings of
the public without having anything they
approved the ridiculous you don't have
to look at signatures
you don't have to approve anything you
can have double mailings
so we're 90 seconds in here not even and
trump is lying uncontrollably he's
claiming that what nevada did is somehow
pernicious i'll talk about that later
he's talking about you know you can have
double mailings you don't need
signatures
none of that is true nevada approved
sending
absentee ballots to registered voters
who went through the normal process for
voter registration if you did it at the
registry of motor vehicles
they have your signature it was the
appropriate process there are other
opportunities of course to register to
vote you have to be a citizen all of
that stuff applies
it's just sending ballots to registered
voters
let's keep going you can have all sorts
of things nobody's ever seen
anything like it it's a disgrace i mean
honestly it's a disgrace
so it's a very good question i mean the
uh the male imbalance if you look at
just some of the
small the small places the small races
congressional race in new york um
it should be very easy normally that
would have been announced at seven
o'clock and it would have been
down to the wire and everybody would
have loved it it was
it was at all complex it would have
taken an extra 45 minutes or an hour
they would have announced it a little
bit later
they have no clue this was about six
weeks ago
and they have no clue what's going on
they've lost ballots
there's fraudulent ballots
it's how are you going to do that for an
entire nation
now it is true that the new york
situation is not good
but the problem is not an issue of fraud
it's a logistical problem and it relates
to postmarks and last-minute mailings by
the city of new york
this doesn't excuse the problem there
are problems
around the country whenever we have a
presidential election with in-person
voting voter suppression
voter rolls all of this stuff and many
of those problems are by design
there are concerns here legitimate ones
and we have similar concerns about
in-person voting as well
but this is all fixable stuff and trump
is framing it all as proactive
fraud the post office has said they are
more than equipped to handle the volume
of ballots that's expected in the fall
but trump is trying to kneecap the post
office so in other words trump is trying
to cause problems rather than solve them
and then point to the problems he plans
to exacerbate as reasons why we
shouldn't
do expanded absentee ballot access which
is essentially what we're talking about
no you know trump's trying to create
this false distinction between
vote by mail and absentee ballot and
while in theory they could be two
different things
in practice for november we're talking
about expanding absentee
let's continue they're using covert to
try and get
the mail-in ballots now absentee ballots
are great
absentee ballots they have to request
them they go through a process they get
them
but the universal mail-in ballots have
turned out to be a disaster and
what nevada has been doing if you look
over the last few days
you have to look at what they've done
you can have two ballots
you can harvest it's harvesting so you
can take thousands of ballots put them
together and just dump them down on
somebody's desk
after a certain period of time they have
something where if you vote
the vote can count up to seven days
later well if the vote's going to count
seven days later that means you
you know if it depends on the one state
like nevada
that would mean simply that you can't
have supposing it's down to that one
state it could be
it's a great state but supposing it's
down to that one state
that means you have to wait seven days
again
absentee versus vote by mail uh
the request process etc we're talking
here
about letting anybody vote absentee who
wants to that's what we're talking about
it's not a new system and i'm going to
keep repeating this
endlessly because it has been debunked
it is a distinction that doesn't really
exist in practice
and then trump goes to again you might
not know the results on election night
so what so what trump is saying both
that it's going to be rigged and he
wants the results right away well is it
the worst thing in the world
if it took a few days and we were sure
that we got the right results
that account for the absentee ballots
and we know every vote has been counted
it doesn't sound so bad
let's keep going but they won't have it
there this is something that's
so messed up and by the way i have to
say the post office
for many many years has been you know
run
in a fashion that hasn't been great
great workers and everything but they
have old equipment very old equipment
and i don't think the post office is
prepared for a thing like this you have
to ask the people at the post office but
how can the post office be expected to
handle they have regular mailing
and then now on top of that they have
the internet where you have
amazon and these companies doing you
know all the buying instead of going to
a department store they go
buy through mail so you have massive
numbers of purchases now going through
the post office purchases of items and
gifts
and that's a tremendous strain on the
post office the post office loses a
fortune it has been for many many years
for decades so now on top of it it has
this
and the amazons of the world and the
others they pay
very very little money they lose money
on every the post office loses money
which is ridiculous on every package it
delivers
but now on top of that and i'm not just
referring to amazon i'm talking about
all of the
competitors if there is such a thing to
amazon
there will be so while he's weighing in
on e-commerce trends there
donald trump also throws in that the
post office couldn't handle the volume
of mail and votes
again the post office has said we can
handle it just fine they've put out a
statement saying so but donald trump
wants to prevent
them from being able to handle it by
cutting their funding
which is what his new postmaster general
seems determined to do louis de joy
who is a trump donor and trump is still
going he's still ranting and lying here
but if there is such a thing but now on
top of that
you'll have somebody like the governor
of nevada
come out with this massive plan out of
nowhere
to take millions of ballots and send
them all over the place
you'll never know who won that state
it'll get messed up just like new york
and just like paterson new jersey and
just like many other places
in west virginia they indicted a postman
for doing something very bad you know
that
and but there are many cases all over
the country if you look
you'll be able to find there's a list of
them all over the country
and that has to do with universal
mail-in now this is important
when trump and others cite the few
examples of actual mail-in ballot fraud
those are people who got caught the
system worked
the people didn't get away with it there
are very few examples
and the people got caught that means
that the fraud
was not something they got away with it
was attempted
fraud which was caught this is like
saying
smoke detectors sometimes detect a house
fire
so we shouldn't build houses because
they're not safe no no no no
the smoke detector worked which allows
us
to safely have the houses five minutes
straight
of lie after lie after lie thanks to a
softball question from trump-friendly
media sycophants in the back of the room
it's not dissimilar from north korean
propaganda now
getting to the end of this again i mean
it's just exhausting
with vote by mail versus absentee again
absentee is great it works like in
florida they'll do absentee it really
works
but universal mail-in ballots is going
to
be a great embarrassment to our country
well i have the right to do it we
haven't gotten there yet but we'll see
what happens we will be
suing in nevada and that's already been
taken care of we'll probably file
something tomorrow
i do want to say that we're going to be
introducing a tremendous health care
plan sometime
prior hopefully prior to the end of the
month it's just about completed now
and that's the final point trump
apparently does think he can just make a
presidential decree about vote by mail
but he can't remember that states run
their own elections
they can do as they please within the
law trump can try to sue
but he can't just cancel vote by mail
from the oval office
notice by the way trump does bring up at
the end there
his new health care plan supposedly that
was going to be signed into law 48 hours
ago
now he says it'll be signed into law by
the end of
august that should really be a hoot so
five straight minutes of lying
uh we'll have more of this on our
instagram page
david pakman show on instagram follow us
there
after the break how to vote by mail it's
not tough
it's really not difficult the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
welcome back to the david pakman show
okay so i'm sure by now you all know
what's going on
with voting in november we should vote
the act of voting itself
whether you vote in person or not has
become highly politicized
my take is everybody should vote you
have the opportunity to participate in
deciding who's going to lead our country
i'm not just talking about trump versus
biden i'm talking about the local level
i'm talking about the state level and
you should exercise that right and you
should have a say so people have written
to me and they've said david
with all of this confusion about
absentee versus vote by mail
please explain how to vote by mail so
first of all what we're talking about
for november is
expanded absentee ballot access or you
might call it in some states
universal absentee voting in states that
have decided
to send ballots out they go
only to registered voters they don't go
to undocumented immigrants they don't go
to children
do not fall for those talking points
each state has its own rules so you have
to know the rules of your state or
commonwealth
so first of all figure out the rules in
your state go to the nass
website page called absentee and early
voting
we're linking to that page in the
description to the youtube clip for this
story
you put in your state for example when i
put in massachusetts
it takes me to the massachusetts
secretary of the commonwealth page
with information on how to get an
absentee ballot now massachusetts
sent out absentee ballot applications
automatically
i receive the application if i plan to
vote by mail which i do
i fill it out i send it back in and then
at some point after the september 1st
primary once we know exactly who will be
on the ballot in november
i will get the actual absentee ballot
which is where i vote
now this is not the situation in every
state if you look at the brookings
map rating states on vote by mail
you will see that states range in
ratings from a to f
right now alabama is the only state
rated f
on absentee voting while a bunch of
states get an a
including the three west coast states
utah and colorado
hawaii and washington dc and then a
bunch of states get a b
and this relates to the ease with which
you can access an absentee ballot in
your particular state
now i wish i could tell you this is the
one way
to do this but each state runs things
differently so you actually do
need to go and look at your state's
voting website now a few things to
understand
and again your state's website will tell
you this if you're in the commonwealth
of virginia or the state of florida or
even the state of florida as trump says
the
every state and commonwealth has a
website that will explain this to you
in some states every registered voter
will get a ballot automatically
perfect just confirm you're registered
you can do that on the usa.gov
page confirm you're registered to vote
we're also linking to that if you're
registered and you're in a state that's
sending out
ballots to every registered voter
beautiful in other states
every registered voter will be sent an
application for a ballot which you have
to fill out and send in
in order to request the actual ballot be
sent to you
that's what i did in massachusetts for
example
in some states you have to choose to go
and apply for an absentee ballot now
typically
i think there are some states where it
can be done online in other states you
have to send some
physical piece of mail to request the
absentee ballot
in some states everybody's allowed an
absentee ballot
in other states you have to give a valid
reason
for why you want to vote absentee and
depending on your state
saying i'm afraid of catching
coronavirus is considered a valid reason
now in other states there's still a
fight going on about that
so you would have to look at the reasons
that are considered valid reasons for
requesting an absentee ballot in your
state
and match it to your situation i'm not
suggesting
anybody lie but examine what the valid
reasons are
and determine whether any of them match
your
circumstances it's tragic that this is
what's going on
but all we can do given that voting
in some states starts in four and a half
weeks
is to go to your state's website if you
have to request something
do it now and stay on top of this this
really isn't difficult and i understand
when you hear well am i getting a ballot
or am i getting an application
do i have to print the application or
can i fill it out online i get it
we have 50 different systems in the
united states all of the links you need
are in the description to this youtube
video clip
if anybody you know is at all confused
about how to vote by mail
send them this clip we did a story on
the bonus show where we discussed that
a whole bunch of people including in
particular young people
aren't sure how to vote by mail how to
request an absentee ballot or whether
they will get one automatically
that's exactly the confusion we are
trying to resolve here
figure out what's going on in your state
using the links provided in the
description for this youtube clip
it is not difficult you have a right to
vote in most states now
you have a right to vote absentee if you
go through the right process
take advantage of things that are
offered to you because the stakes quite
frankly could not be higher
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your chemex or french
press or
a david pakman show t-shirt it's all
available
on our website shipping to anywhere in
the world
at davidpakman.com gear don't miss the
bumper stickers too
davidpakman.com forward slash gear
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so the state of nevada did something
very important yesterday
and after they did it donald trump
absolutely exploded in another one of
these fits of rage
what nevada did is they approved sending
every registered voter an absentee
ballot
rather than sending out applications
which have to be returned in order to
get an absentee ballot instead of saying
simply
if you want an absentee ballot you have
to print
and send us the absentee ballot
application they
uh had approved by the state legislature
and expected to be signed into law by
the democratic governor
a bill which will say if you're a
registered voter we will send you
a ballot donald trump immediately took
to twitter to furiously say
quote in an illegal late night coup
nevada's clubhouse governor made it
impossible for republicans to win the
state
post office could never handle the
traffic of mail-in votes without
preparation
using covid to steal the state
see you in capital c court
now it's actually a linguistic
feat that donald trump has accomplished
squeezing so many lies and distortions
into such a small number of characters
it's interesting that this is now
sort of the battle line when it comes to
the election
and how and when the november election
will take place has become one of the
biggest stories among many big stories
right now
donald trump first of all claiming that
it is illegal for nevada to do this it's
not
states run their own elections they can
do this if they want they are not
sending absentee ballots as trump says
multiple ballots to the same people
or ballots to kids or undocumented
immigrants or whatever the case may be
ballots are going to registered voters
and states have a right to do that
secondly it is not impossible for
republicans to win with mail-in voting
in a literal sense but donald trump
seems to recognize that in order to win
he needs to suppress the vote
and he disproportionately needs to
suppress the democratic vote since
democrats take the virus more seriously
than republicans if you make it more
difficult to vote or
at least more risky in terms of catching
the virus to vote
you will probably dissuade more
democrats than republicans from voting
it's a simple numbers game and the
polling i showed you yesterday bears
that out
democrats by taking coronavirus more
seriously
might be more likely to say if i have to
go in person i'll i'm going to stay home
whereas republicans because they are not
taking the viruses seriously are more
likely to say
if i can't vote by mail i will go in and
vote so it's a strategy and it's a very
clear strategy
notice also that donald trump mentions
the post office can't handle the traffic
of mail-in ballots
he himself is trying to kneecap the post
office
he appointed as postmaster general a big
donor to his campaign louis de joy
louis de joy immediately decided to
restrict overtime for postal workers we
talked about it in detail earlier
and it looks as though louis de joy is
also starting to explore
the possibility of closing some post
office
branches so again trump citing problems
that he is causing
as the reason why we shouldn't do
something and then lastly
you know see you in court is is accurate
in a sense and trump
is filing lawsuits that might be a
preview of what we can expect in
november depending on what the results
of the election
are we may see many elements
of this tied up in court and what trump
is essentially saying is
how can i possibly win if every american
is easily allowed to vote without fear
of catching the virus that's
fundamentally what this is about it is
completely authoritarian it is
completely anti-democratic and the
answer
is if everybody really is able to vote
safely
trump may not be able to win if you look
at the polling
and you look at the partisan split on
vote by mail versus vote in person
it is not a crazy suggestion to make
that if the will of the people is
accurately represented and not hampered
by
kneecapping the post office or
preventing vote by mail
trump may not be able to win because
people want to vote him out now
the polling may change and of course
trump may suppress enough of the
democratic vote that he does get
re-elected but
he may accurately be perceiving that
although he wouldn't say it in those
words
now lastly uh this idea of the post
office
being unable to handle mail-in ballots
certainly
trump is trying to make it so that they
wouldn't be able to handle it but as it
stands today
the post office would be very well
equipped to handle mail-in ballots
the post office handles unconscionable
numbers of pieces of mail
and as long as we don't deliberately
destroy the post office which is what
trump is trying to do
the post office will have no problem
handling mail so fundamentally this
comes down to what is
one of the few strategies trump now has
to take control of the election i told
you
about that poll yesterday which showed
two-thirds of those planning to vote in
person are trump supporters
whereas 75 percent of those planning to
vote by mail
are biden supporters that is the data
which explains
why trump is so furiously against
vote by mail trump's strategy is not to
be a good president so people want to
vote for him
that opportunity has sadly come and gone
the strategy is suppress the vote
suppress the vote while kneecapping the
post office try to prevent vote by mail
in order to try to sneak into another
four years in office
we can't allow it to happen but we need
to vote in order to prevent it
okay let's now go back to the delay of
the election
idea that was floated months ago joe
biden said that
he believed donald trump was going to
try to create some kind of emergency as
a pretext to delay the election
and a whole bunch of people said oh joe
biden's crazy trump's not going to do
that
and then last week donald trump floated
the idea on twitter
of delaying the election and has since
insisted at every opportunity that this
is going to be a rigged
phony election a top democratic
congressman in the house
now specifically says that donald trump
is going to use emergency powers to
remain in the white house if he loses
the election
so this idea is not about delaying the
election
it's about declaring an emergency if he
loses
to not vacate the white house now i'm
talking here about house majority whip
congressman james clyburn this is
probably the strongest reaction from an
actual
federal lawmaker so far saying trump's
idea is to put a cloud over the election
and then use some kind of an emergency
to justify staying in the oval office
here is congressman clyburn himself on
cnn sunday
do you really think donald trump is
comparable to adolf hitler
what i said started about two and a half
maybe three years ago after one of his
state of the unions
but i feel very strongly that this
man has taken on a strong-armed tactics
and i feel very strongly that she
is mussolini putin is hitler
i said that back then and i believe that
i believe very strongly
this guy never had any idea
about being one to peacefully
transfer power i don't think he plans to
leave
the white house he doesn't plan to have
fair and unfettered
elections i believe that he
plans to install himself in some kind of
emergency way
to continue to hold on to office and
that's why the american people
had better wake up now you know there
are people who are not particularly
pleased with clyburn especially because
he's mentioning you know mussolini and
hitler in the same breath as trump
for me what's lacking is a more detailed
explanation about how
exactly trump plans to do it and so
absent a specific plan
i still don't see this as something that
donald trump could actually get away
with but
understand that this is a different idea
than delaying the election delaying the
election is what trump floated last week
the idea here is
trump loses but then uses some kind of
emergency declaration to try to stay in
power so a few different things number
one
even republicans are saying all of these
ideas are bogus marco rubio saying
you know trump can suggest delaying the
election but that's not what's going to
happen
i think that there's actually a point
where the the idea of of debating this
is arguably the problem and let me
explain to you what i mean
um when you bring on experts
politicians whoever to argue about
can trump delay the election could he
use an emergency to
stay in power or whatever you are
legitimizing the idea of this as a
concept and what i mean by that is
the real newsworthiness of this story
is the wildly authoritarian completely
unhinged idea of delaying the election
that's what needs to be reported on
when you bring in a member of congress
or a legal expert and say could trump do
this or
how could trump do this or is trump
doing this justified
you are creating the notion that there's
something to debate here
i do a bit of a different type of show
than what you see on corporate media so
i've pointed out
trump can't really do this states run
their own elections you need
at the federal level some kind of decree
from the house and senate which you're
not going to get
but the focus of this story needs to be
on corporate media that donald trump is
alluding to something completely
authoritarian and dictatorial it is the
idea
of something that despots do and
normalizing this idea of a delay or
staying in power
is almost saying it could be justified
if there is a debate as to whether trump
would have the legal authority to do
this
it validates what should be
a completely immediately dismissed
authoritarian idea
that's my concern about some of these
types of segments
so i'm curious to hear from you about
that let me know what you think
we have a voicemail number which is two
one
nine two david p here is a voicemail i
received
about potential trump versus biden
debates let's take a listen
hey david this is aristotle from uh
modesto california i just had a quick
question
um what do you think about the debates
that will be happening with
joe biden and donald trump because
obviously joe biden has
emphasized that and is also excited to
debate trump and do you think joe
biden's gonna you know
maybe sweep the floor with trump on the
debates because
at this point on the show you have
covered that
trump has been sweaty and just very just
nervous on everything so do you think
trump's gonna be a nervous wreck and
that would would that give joe biden a
advantage let me know and also
uh i love the show okay yeah got cut off
there but that seemed like it was a very
very uh worthwhile praise of the david
pakman show
so a couple different things number one
i don't know if there are going to be
debates i
at this point i really don't know i said
before i don't care if there are debates
this is
an election where i am uniquely
unconcerned with debates
we know the the differences are so vast
between these candidates that i don't
need debates i don't need conventions i
don't i really don't need any of this
stuff
um the the path forward is very clear
now
if we learned anything from the bernie
versus biden debate remember when the
democratic primary got down to just
bernie versus biden you had a lot of
people saying oh my god dementia joe
he's going to implode bernie's going to
mop the floor with him
and take over the primary and it was
just like very uneventful and
biden did fine enough and as we know he
ended up very easily winning the primary
in general the expectation that debates
are going to dramatically turn the race
i think are overblown expectations that
being said
cognitively trump is not where he was
three and a half years ago
and i readily admit that joe biden has
also slowed down
notably over the last 10 years you know
since he debated paul ryan i guess that
was eight years ago in 2012
joe biden also he's close to 80 years
old and it's a different joe biden i
don't uh
have any interest in pretending that's
not the case so
there is always the possibility that uh
either of the uh candidate could
do sort of self-inflicted damage due to
a poor debate performance
but anybody suggesting that it's clear
that the debates are going to be so
one-sided that it will
destroy one candidate's possibilities um
i i don't see that as as based in fact
and
again i don't know that there are going
to be debates we will hopefully learn
specifics about that soon we have a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about some who are calling for
biden to simply refuse to debate trump
we'll talk about the optics versus the
strategy uh and
we will talk about these mystery seeds
that americans are receiving
i actually received some of these and i
have a story to tell about this
and we will discuss that and so much
more on today's bonus show
two ways to get access to the bonus show
become a member at joinpacman.com
or become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show